il est symptomatique de voir
régulièrement des tuiles des bouts de
tuiles tombées comme ce beau morceau là
des murs qui tombent en ruine une
végétation envahissante la petite
commune de bazoches sur guyonne ne peut
assumer le coût de l'entretien de cette
église romane du 12e siècle pour l'aider
la commune de 600 habitants a fait appel
à l'agencé ingéniérie créé par le
département
sa dernière va l'aider à hauteur de 6000
euros par an et un carnet d'entretien
qui a été dessiné par l'agencé généreux
et qui est un cas un entretien qui va
nous permettre de mettre en oeuvre les
petites opérations d'entretien extérieur
de l'édifice
lagence ingéniérie vais également
conseillé la mairie dans ses choix
d'artisans là on a vraiment besoin de
faire un décapage complet de la porte
d'un traitement du bois et on ne peut
pas évidemment prendre n'importe quel
artisan pour faire ce travail là puisque
l'église est inscrite à l'inventaire
supplémentaire des monuments historiques
et donc on prendra un homme de l'art pas
tenté pour faire ce genre de travaux à
20 km de là année zélande village de
1100 habitants c'est un centre de
loisirs de 44 enfants qui a bénéficié du
soutien d'ingénierie en 2017 de la
conception de l'aménagement à la
réalisation
la partie administrative la partie
financière passat un soutien très très
très important
au total ingénierie a aidé à monter plus
de 340 projet depuis sa création 2014
dans le secteur du bâtiment de
l'urbanisme et de la voirie l' agence
technique est même devenu indispensable
selon son président
quand vous prenez un budget
d'investissement d'une petite commune
c'est ce bon sens où deux cent mille
euros et le moindre projet c'est 300 400
mille euros de peuvent pas des dizaines
de nouveaux projets sont déjà à l'étude
pour la fin de l'année au total le
budget d'ingéniérie avoisine les 800
mille euros